Let's play a game, shall we?
The Saw series is one of the most bloody successful
horror franchises of all time, and Jigsaw's
work is still far from "game over."
Saw: Legacy will splatter 2017 with some all-new
trap-happy mayhem dealing.
So, to prepare for the gruesomeness still
to come, here's a look at the untold truth
of Saw and how it became such a beloved gorefest
in the first place.
Keep watching, or don’t — make your choice.
Cheap tricks
Like a lot of budding auteurs, Leigh Whannell
and James Wan had almost no money to make
their first movie together, so they had to
think cheap when coming up with the bare bones
of their fright flick.
And what’s more budget-friendly than an
entire movie about two guys stuck in a single
room together?
At first, they thought of having their characters
stuck in an elevator with the whole movie
made up of the security footage -- a concept
which might’ve prevented M. Night Shyamalan’s
Devil from ever happening, but who knows.
Wan even conceived of a Paranormal Activity-like
home footage concept before that series came
to be, but ultimately they settled on the
dank bathroom setting that would become so
iconic to the series.
First blood
To court investors, Whannell and Wan made
a short film on a shoestring budget that showcased
the duo's originality and money-saving savvy.
In it, Whannell starred as the character who
has to rifle around in a living friend’s
intestines to find the key to the reverse
bear trap on his head, and that role would
eventually be played in the full film by actress
Shawnee Smith, whom James Wan had a major
crush on since he was a kid.
The spec also featured a Billy puppet made
by Wan himself, using ping-pong balls, paper
towel tubes, and papier mâché, and the design
was so creeptastic that they didn’t bother
changing it for the full film.
Head case
The idea for John "Jigsaw" Kramer, the mastermind
behind most of the series' sinister games,
stemmed from a surprising source: Whannell's
own cranial treatment.
The writer had been experiencing migraines
and when he went through some testing, he
imagined what it would be like to get the
bad news of his own impending expiration date
and how someone might react.
He might not have had a medical issue, but
his mind was definitely twisted.
Show me the money
After Saw proved to be a surprise runaway
hit at the box office — grossing $103 million
worldwide against a reported $1.2 million
budget — actor Cary Elwes was pretty displeased
with the comparatively small slice of the
pie he received from the proceeds.
In a suit filed against the production companies
and producers, Elwes alleged that he was only
paid about $55,000 in all, even though he
was promised at least 1% of the producer profits.
He sought half a million in damages, and the
parties eventually settled out of court.
The acrimony must not have lasted long, because
Elwes came back to the franchise to reprise
his Doctor Gordon role a few films later.
"Congratulations Doctor Gordon, you survived."
Desperate for the sequel
Given the massive success of the first movie,
Lionsgate was in a rush to get Saw II moving
right away, and the producers thought outside
of the bathroom box for the second installment.
Up-and-comer Darren Lynn Bousman had already
written a screenplay for his own film called
The Desperate, but it was criticized for being
too similar to Saw, so producers saw an opportunity
to tinker with Bousman's flick and transform
it into a follow-up for their own.
His foray into the Saw series was so successful
that he remained on board as a director of
the third and fourth films as well.
Sticking point
Although nearly all of the traps in the Saw
series were complicated, none could be more
labor-intensive than the needle pit scene
from Saw II.
120,000 needles were needed to fill the prickly
vat, and it took a round-the-clock team four
days to replace the real needles with fiber
optic tips for Shawnee Smith’s safety.
After all that prep making the site poke-free,
a crew member accidentally knocked a pile
of real needles back into the heap, so they
had to halt production before it could even
begin to locate them.
Director Bousman later joked on Reddit that
"it was like finding a needle in a needle
stack.”
Good one.
Good blood
As a nod to all the onscreen bloodshed in
the first two Saw films, Saw III's theatrical
promotion included a poster made using a real
vial of actor Tobin Bell's blood, mixed with
red ink to create the most visually jarring
shade for his cloak in the image.
Lionsgate printed 1,000 copies of the design
and auctioned it off to benefit the Red Cross,
in addition to hosting a series of blood drives
organized by the studio that raised thousands
of pints for the organization.
Toilet humor
There's very little levity to be seen onscreen
in the Saw series, but behind the scenes,
the cast and crew found ways to keep the mood
light.
One running gag during production was the
use of a hidden fart machine that was set
off during particularly difficult scenes,
just to mess with the actors:
"Hahahaha, hahahaha. Look, he's still acting!"
That's not all.
During Bell's nude morgue scene, his splayed
out exposure got him "cupped" in the nether
regions by co-stars.
Talk about your crude humor.
Friendly favors
Rather than rebuild the bathroom set from
the first film for Saw III, the filmmakers
simply called in a favor to the makers of
Scary Movie 4 and used their replica … minus
the basketball hoop and falling pipe, of course.
"Damnit"
Oopsie daisy
In 2010, one Massachusetts theater full of
children was supposed to show an innocent
screening of the animated flick Megamind,
but that wasn't the film that actually started
to roll.
Instead, it was Saw 3D.
Some of the children supposedly experienced
nightmares after seeing the first few minutes,
which is understandable considering the opening
scene has two men who have to hacksaw their
shared girlfriend to save themselves.
Sleep tight, kids!
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Saw story you liked most...